[Musique]
sa recrute sur TV 78 l'émission qui
parle emploi dans le département à
chaque numéro son invité qui vient nous
parler de son secteur ou de son
entreprise qui recrute et ce soir dans
sa recrute nous recevons Paul Boutreux
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes le responsable
recrutement chez Socotec alors pour ceux
qui ne connaissent pas ce groupe c'est
quoi sookotec quelles sont ses
activitésors tout d'abord merci de
m'avoir invité le groupe socotek on est
un des leaders mondiaux dans le domaine
d'éthiqu test inspection et
certification le groupe socotek il
emploie 11500 collaborateurs à travers
26 pays et si je reviens sur la France
cela représente 5500 collaborateurs
répartis à travers 190 Agen en d'autres
termes on a un tier indépendant de
confiance et on va aller inspecter des
bâtiments et des infrastructures pour
des acteurs dans le domaine de la
construction du bâtiments et des
infrastructures en France à l'étranger
le groupe recrute en ce moment 1400
personnes en France 400 rien que pour
l'Île-deFrance où le groupe est présent
avec 42 agences locales et on va en
parler avec vous dans cette émission
justement il y a aussi Clara de Frutos
qui est avec nous comme chaque numéro de
sa recrute bonsoir journaliste
économique de la rédaction de tv78 vous
avez proposé à nos téléspectateurs trois
offres d'emploi disponibles dès à
présent sur le territoire ben dans quel
métier y y a-t-il des besoins en ce
moment et ben j'ai sélectionné un métier
d'assistant dentaire auxiliaire de vie
et pâtissier parce qu'il y a trois
entreprises qui recherchent activement à
50 an iveline suivre aussi dans sa
recrute le conseil de France travail ex
Pôle emploi pour maximiser vos chances
d'être embauché ce sera tout à l'heure
dans sa
[Musique]
recrute alors sookotque on en parle avec
vous Paul Boutreux c'est 1140
collaboratoire rien que pour
l'Île-deFrance un groupe présent aussi
dans les evelines on le voit sur ces
images le siège est implanté à guancour
nouveau siège he depuis 2018 y a-t-il
aussi d'autres implantations en en
Île-de-France parmi les 42 agences local
dont je parlais tout à l'heure tout à
fait alors le groupe sootque la maison m
est basé dans à encore dans 78 il y a
environ 400 collaborateurs dans 78 et
nous avons également des agences à la
défense à villeepin dans le 93 dans le
95 dans le 77 et à maison ALFOR dans le
94 donc grosse implantation dans dans
lesin ex on couvre de l'Î de France tout
à fait et donc lesémission de sookotek
sont le test l'inspection et la
certification donc sur quel grand projet
travaille le groupe en ce moment et
est-ce que les Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques
2024 font partie alors en effet vous me
tendez une belle perche avec les Jeux
Olympiques forcément nous sommes un des
acteurs un des contributeurs afin que
les Jeux Olympiques se déroulent le
mieux possible pour citer pour en citer
deux trois exemples nous avons le centre
aquatique à Saint-Denis nous allons
inspecter l'ensemble du centre aquatique
nous avons le parcours des Jeux
Olympiques lorsqu'il va se s'ouvrir
l'inspection de tous les ponts pour être
sûr et certain que le jourg tout se
déroule bien pour la cérémonie
d'ouverture exactement et tout va bien
se dérouler je VO rassure dans déjà euh
et le troisème c'est le que j'ai en tête
c'est le vélodrome qui est à côté nous
le site de gu en cours nous avons nous
avons l'inspection de de l'ensemble du
site tout à fait donc de de gros projets
pour cette année 2024 une année
olympique alors pour les mener à bien
justement l'entreprise table sur 1400
recrutements cette année en France donc
400 rien que pour l'île-de- France mais
pourquoi ces recrutements sont-ils
nécessaires c'est pour accompagner votre
développement tout simplement exactement
pour vous donner deux chiffres l'E
dernière on a clôturé un chiffre
d'affaires à 1 milliard 3 7 ans en
arrière on était à peine à 500 millions
d'euros donc une croissance x 2 un
doublement de l'a de l'effectif une
présence à l'internationale qui est
accrue et pour accompagner notre
croissance nous devons recruter des
nouveaux collaborateurs parce que nos
carnets de commande sont plein dans tous
les secteurs d'activité nous sommes un
généraliste auprès de nos clients et de
ce fait nous avons trois grandes entités
en France qui recrutent donc équipement
et industrie qui va recruter des
techniciens des chargés d'affaires en
électricité électrotechnique donc sur du
niveau BTS licence nous avons une
deuxième entité qui s'appelle
construction immobilier qui va recruter
des ingénieurs en contrôle technique
dans le domaine de la construc
construction du BTP donc là on est
plutôt sur des modèles master Ingénierie
ingénieur et enfin notre dernière qui
est environnement et formation qui va
recrouter aussi bien des techniciens que
des ingénieurs qui vont aller inspecter
les les sitites et sol P de
l'environnement de l'écologie pour
assurer la transition écologique chez
tous nos clients donc des besoins
multiples variés différents métiers
différents niveaux d'études de compéten
aussi qui sont recherchés tout à fait
ouais le le le panel est vraiment très
large et c'est ce qui rend l'entreprise
intéressante et enrichissante parce que
toutes les diversités de profils sont
chezokotch vous pouvez arriver chez nous
après une une carrière de 20 25 ans ne
pas du tout connaître d'autres métier et
pourtant on va vous former dès dès que
vous passez la porte du groupe socotch
vous avez un plan de formation qui est
mise en place donc soit vous vous
dirigez vers une expertise technique et
on vous accompagne tout au long de votre
carrière en vous proposant des
formations des modules delearning du
compagnonage et cetera soit vous vous
dirigez vers une carrière managéiale
avec une prédisposition à encadrer des
équipes et là on a créé un partenariat
avec une école de commerce qui s'appelle
le M lon avec laquelle nous nous formons
l'ensemble de nos collaborateurs vers
des bonnes pratiques managériales pour
pour performer avec avec tous nos
collaborateur cl vous avz une question
oui est-ce que ces métiers ils sont en
tension est-ce que c'est difficile
d'embaucher dans dans ce type de métier
ou pas il est vrai que nous
rencontrons al non pas des difficultés à
embaucher car j'ai beaucoup de chance
c'est une très belle équipe recroutement
interne qui connaît très bien son métier
euh et nous avons plusieurs leviers pour
être attractif auprès de ces jeunes
talents premièrement l'aspect formation
euh les évolutions de carrière vous
pouvez évoluer de manière aussi bien
verticale qu'horizontale vous pouvez
également changer d'activité au cours de
votre emploi chez sootch c'estàdire
qu'un un technicien en électricité peut
devenir chargé d'ffire électricité chez
construction qui est un autre modèle qui
n'a rien à voir on vous accompagne en
interne et on vous fait grandir et on a
différents modules de formation
imaginons un jeune collaborateur qui
nous rejoint qui a un BEP pro qui se dit
ah mince ce coté recrute à partir d'un
niveau B et ben non nous avons créé
notre programme CFA qui a une
reconnaissance avec le gouvernement qui
a un titre qui est reconnu qui a une
valeur de diplôme et pendant 1 an nous
accompagnons ces ces futurs
vérificateurs technique électricité 6
mois de d'apprentissage 6 mois de
compagnage et à la au bout d'un an ils
ont un CDI au bout de de cet
apprentissage on voit quelques images
finalement vous les accompagnez au sein
de l'entreprise mais avant même qu'il
soit dans dans l'entreprise fin avec ce
CFA ce dispositif exctement c'est un
programme d'alternance qui dure un an et
c'est tout se déroule bien il transforme
l'essai en CDI et on a de très beaux
taux de transformation donc on on appuie
encore sur cette campagne pour augmenter
nos nos capacités de d'intégration pour
ses futurs collaborateurs sur le
programme CFA et on travaille également
avec une association pour un programme
qui s'appelle rebond favorable là ce
sont des jeunes qui sont essus de de
quartiers défavorisés qui souhaitent se
réinsérer dans le monde du travail et on
les accompagne dans ce sens donc c'est
des métiers variés on l'a compris grande
diversité est-ce qu'il y a tout de même
des compétences des des qualités que
vous recherchez dans vos futurs
collaborateur moi je dis toujours à mes
collaborateurs et aux futurs
collaborateurs la curiosité n'est pas un
vilain défaut si vous avez envie
d'apprendre un nouveau métier si vous
êtes curieux de d'un peu de tout de
savoir comment ça fonctionne derrière
qu'est-ce qui se passe der derrière un
pont un tunnel un bâtiment comment
l'érie comment il est durable dans le
temps rejoignez sokotch c'est l'esprit
c'est vraiment le trait de caractère qui
est primordial et ensuite on vous
accompagne on vous fait monter en en
puissance sur les sur les sujets ça ça
fait partie des valeurs de l'entreprise
de faire monter en fait on a
c'est notre PDG RV monjotin qui dit très
bien il le dit en anglais il dit you gr
we gr vous grandissez nous grandissons
si les collaborateurs grandissent
s'enrichissent techniquement
managéialement parlant le groupe sootch
va forcément grandir alors on y est
formé on peut aussi évoluer vous l'avez
dit dans ce côté qu'est-ce qu'on y est
bien payé quelle est la fourchette de
salaire là pour les métiers dont vous
nous parlez nous sommes dans dans le
standard nous sommes vraiment dans les
standards dans le domaine d'éthique que
ce soit au niveau des concurrents direct
au niveau de de la concurrence que j'ai
appelle indirect les acteurs de
l'énergie de la transformation et cetera
nous sommes vraiment dans dans ce dans
ce mê m fait donc plutôt attractif cl
avec des avantage type également
véhicule de fonction intéressement
participation qui participe au au
bien-être également de de nos
collaborateurs des avantages également à
rejoindre l'entreprise tout àit et alors
comment on fait pour candidater donc
dans votre entreprise sookotec alors
pour candidater le plus simple c'est le
notre site carrière donc sookotque.fr il
y a un onglet carrière et là vous allez
sélectionner l'offre qui qui vous
convient si à tout hasard vous ne
trouvez pas une offre mais ça
m'étonnerait mais si à tout hasard cela
arrive il y a un onglet candidature
spontané vous déposez votre CD et
ensuite quelqu'un en interne fera le le
dispatch pour trouver le bon
interlocuteur pour pour appeler le
candidat donc il y a un objectif de 400
on en est où est-ce qu'il y a déjà des
collaborateurs qui ont été recrutés ou
ça se lance maintenant alors c'est c'est
en flux continu finalement c'est en flux
continu parce qu'on a on a dévoiler en
fin d'année dernière notre ambition 2028
où on souhaite grandir faire des
nouvelles acquisition faire de la
croissance organique en France donc
finalement c'est en fluxue là vous voyez
pour vous donner un chiffre qui est
plutôt plaisant à dire et à entendre on
a uniquement sur une entité 100
collaborateurs qui vont nous rejoindre
entre janvier février et mars et 100
collaborateurs que nous allons former de
A à Z et donc le site s'est affiché he
pour et bien postuler vous l'avez dit
sur le site socotek.fr rubrique carrière
Clara vous allez nous donner dans un
instant trois offres d'emploi disponibl
sur le territoire juste avant le conseil
de France travail ex Pôle emploi pour
être embauché ce soir ça concerne le
fameux CV qu'il vaut mieux éviter de
trop charger regardez la photo sur le le
le CV ce n'est pas toujours
obligatoire l'âge n'est pas une
information qui qui qui est importante
sachant que afin de définir l'âge d'un
candidat il nous suffit d'aller voir au
niveau de l'expérience professionnelle
des diplômes des formations et la
réponse en là tout de suite ce qu'il
faut éviter c'est vraiment de mettre
beaucoup d'informations qui soi inutile
qui ne soit pas vraiment
importante et en lien direct avec le
besoin et l'offre d'emploi et ce que
demande et ce que recherche
l'employeur voilà pour ce conseil et
Clara on va terminer cette émission avec
vous comme chaque numéro vous proposz à
nos téléspectateurs des offres d'emploi
qui sont disponible en ce moment même
sur le territoire des Evelin et on
commence avec jober Group qui a de gros
besoins de recrutement oui le groupe
recherche activement des assistant
dentaire en CDI à Plaisir montinil
bretonux trappe et au clés sous-bois
alors pour ce vous serez amené à
assister les praticiens lors des
consultations stériliser les instruments
accueillir les patients gérer des
commandes préparer des plateaux
techniques mais aussi conseiller et
prévenir les patients sur l'hygiène
bucot en terre et quelles sont les
compétences recherchées pour ce poste
alors jober group recherche quelqu'un de
souriant de dynamique et de rigoureux
vous devez aussi être titulaire d'un
diplôme d'assistant dentaire et pour ce
qui est de la rémunération jober Group
propose un salaire entre 2000 et 2400 €
brut par mois alors pour la deuxième
offre d'emploi on reste dans le secteur
social médical vous nous proposez un
poste d'auxiliaire de vie oui parce que
comme jober group l'entreprise AAE a de
gros besoins en recrutement et cherche à
embaucher des auxiliaires de vie
notamment à trappe aux clés sous-bois et
à plaisir alors pour ce poste votre
principale mission sera de rendre de
vous rendre chez les bénéficiaires de
façon autonome et ensuite les
accompagner dans les différentes
activités du quotidien donc vous devrez
donc entretenir leur domicile aider leur
déplacement leurs toilettes et la
confection et la prise de leur repas
vous devrez aussi être présent lors de
leur sorties pour ce qui est des
compétences AE recherche quelqu'un de
passionné de bienveillant et animé par
la volonté d'aider les autres il faudra
aussi avoir une bonne capacité
d'adaptation et un sens des
responsabilités pour ce poste pas besoin
d'avoir de diplôme particuliers AE
propose même d'accompagner et de former
les postulants par contre pour le pour
le salaire rien n'est spécifié et pour
la dernière offre offre d'emploi vous
nous proposez un poste chez Lior oui
l'un de leur restaurant d'entreprise
situé à guillencour recrute un un
pâtissier en CDI alors vos principales
missions pour ce poste seront de
participer à l'élaboration de la carte
des desserts puis les produire assurer
le dressage et la finition des
pâtisseries pour avoir de jolies
présentations veillez constamment à la
qualité visuelle et gustative des
desserts mais aussi réaliser des
dressages minutes et conseiller les
clients lors du service on termine avec
les compétences quelles sont-elles alors
hor cherche quelqu'un de passionné par
la pâtisserie évidemment être créatif et
soucieux et pour ce poste vous devez
aussi maîtriser et connaître les
techniques pâtissières une formation CAP
be en pâtisserie est demandée vous devez
aussi disposer d'une expérience de plus
de 5 ans minimum dans le monde de la
pâtisserie et cette fois-ci encore pour
le salaire aucune fourchette n'est
indiquée merci clar ces offres d'emploi
sont disponibles et à retrouver sur
différents sites là vous les avez trouvé
toutes sur le site le portail SK en
loi.fr qui propose différentes offres de
job à Saint-Quentin en Yveline voilà
c'est la fin de sa recrute merci d'avoir
été avec nous merci également à Paul
Boutreux responsable recrutement à
sookotch je rappelle que le groupe
embauche 400 ingénieurs et techniciens
en lîdefance peut-être un mot de la fin
pour pour terminer nous vous attendons
nombreux merci encore merci à Clara
d'avoir été avec nous on se retrouve
dans de semaines pour un prochain numéro
de sa recrute d'ici là passer
d'excellentes journées sur
tv78
[Musique]